one of the dumbest things about our
culture and I hesitate in saying that
because I realize it's quite a statement
there are so many dumb things to choose
from but I do believe one of the dumbest
is how you aren't allowed to dislike
female-led action movies and that's why
Ghostbusters which is more of an action
comedy with big fat scare quotes around
action and comedy but was it was
critically acclaimed
despite being mediocre at best and also
being an absolute swan dive in terms of
quality in comparison to the originals
and that's why Wonder Woman was praised
in the kind of effusive ecstatic almost
poetic terms that we usually reserved
for Renaissance art because that's the
way it works if you have if it's a
female action movie and it's bad then
you have to say that it's at least
pretty good but if it's a female action
movie that's already pretty good or
decent then it's amazing incredible the
grades it's a cinematic achievement
which is why a Wonder Woman was at most
okay that's the most you could possibly
say about it in objective terms but you
aren't allowed to be objective when it
comes to female action movies and now
Captain Marvel is coming on the movie
Captain Marvel with brie Larson the
woman who said she doesn't want white
men reviewing her movie and she promises
it will be the the and I quote the
biggest feminist movie of all time which
the biggest feminist movie of all time
is a superhero movie which is is
literally the worst possible way to sell
a superhero movie you could not think of
a worst market marketing pitch than that
you may as well try to sell a horror
film by saying it's the cutest love
story of all time you're using a sales
pitch that is exactly the opposite of
what almost everyone in that genres
fanbase wants but that's what brie
Larson said and and in any case it's a
big big feminist movie and men aren't
allowed to review it others have echoed
this this set
Alisa Klein is apparently a film
journalist according to our Twitter
Twitter bio and she was on Twitter
yesterday blasting the mail critics who
dared to review this movie and not just
dared to review it but some of them if
you can believe it gave it a negative
review and so she was she was sort of
busily posting all of the negative
reviews from men and tried to SiC her
followers on these people before for
daring to dislike the movie meanwhile
webs a website a feminist website called
the Mary Sue claimed that all of the
negative reviews of this movie which
comes out on Friday all of the the
negative reviews are from from from men
you know this has become a rallying cry
among feminists and as always with these
things but it's not true by the way
there are plenty of women who have given
a negative reviews as well but just
think about the stupidity in the fact
that there is even a rallying cry at all
around a movie about a magical ninja in
a rubber suit who goes around shooting
lasers out of her out of her hands or
eyes or what I think there are lasers
involved right with Captain Marvel I'm
not sure but usually there is with
superheroes now there are articles being
written about the the controversy
surrounding Captain Marvel reviews
what's the controversy well the
controversy is that some people didn't
like it
that's what the controversy is they
didn't like it because in their opinion
it just wasn't a very good movie as far
as I'm aware there hasn't been any
review written by a man taking issue
with the movie because brie Larson
should have been in the kitchen making
her Man a lasagna rather than messing
around with all the superhero stuff okay
that's that's not what anyone who say
that no one is saying that's man's work
woman now get rid of that cape and that
put on an apron that's where you belong
no that's not that's not what no man as
far as I know no man is saying that it's
just some people have said yeah you know
it's not a great movie it's okay it's
just not great I mean that's what some
people have said
but feminists respond to that criticism
with a banshee like shrieking which is
how they respond to everything because
you're not allowed to like a movie about
a girl kicking but if it's if it's a
butt-kicking girl movie you're not
allowed to date you have to like it you
cannot not like it which is why it's
kind of funny and I recommend after
after I'm after the show go to go to
Rotten Tomatoes the review aggregator
site and and check out the reviews of
this movie the review started coming out
yesterday yeah there are like I said
there are some negative reviews
including some negative reviews from
women but most critics will not dare to
write a fully negative review about a
female led action movie they just won't
do it
because they know that they this is a
stupid everything is that they know they
take their careers into their hands if
they commit the sin of disliking a movie
about a woman fighting bad guys so so
what you find on Rotten Tomatoes are a
bunch of critics desperately trying to
find a reason any reason to give this
movie a positive grade it's pretty clear
that's not very very moods kind of
stupid movie but there are all these
critics I think it's got like an 84 85
percent rating on Rotten Tomatoes right
now because all of these critics are
trying to find it they know they have to
like it and so they're finding some way
to like this movie and so let me read
you some of the descriptions from
positive reviews okay these are some of
the some of the adjectives some of the
descriptions that the positive reviews
compiled by Rotten Tomatoes have used
descriptions like convoluted plotting
predictable exhausting shaky and
confused flawed a disappointment
mid-tier not going to reinvent the wheel
forgettable a work in progress okay
these are the positive reviews
of the movie these are people who didn't
like the movie pretty clearly they
thought that it was forgettable dull
boring and disappointment but they they
knew that they had to give it a thumbs
up anyway this is the bigotry of low
expectations on steroids this is yeah
it's a disappointment forgettable dull
boring but it's got a lady in it there's
a woman in it so it must be good
the real reason for all the positive
reviews can be summed up by one of the
the less hesitant positive reviews that
I found one of the reviewers said this
we are still at the point where the
visuals of such a powerful female hero
are rare enough that its sheer existence
makes you giddy okay this is what
someone said the sheer existence of this
movie it doesn't matter if it's good
doesn't matter what it's about just its
sheer existence is enough for you to
praise it the thing that's so funny
about that
is that um I wrote my own review of
Captain Marvel and published it to the
Daily wire yesterday and the title of my
review is a Captain Marvel is a towering
artistic achievement and the joke of
course is that I'm showering the movie
with ridiculous praise simply because I
don't want anyone to call me a sexist
even though I admit that I haven't even
seen the movie and never planned to but
I am keeping all this praise on it but
let me here's a paragraph from my now
keep in mind that real review I just a
snippet of that real review that I just
read to you here's a snippet of my fake
satirical review I said does brie Larson
do a good job acting in the movie well
your question is stunningly misogynistic
brie Larson isn't there to impress you
you have no right to judge her
performance she's not a puppet dancing
on your string you scum all you need to
know is that Larson is there in the film
existing breathing being her performance
was already magnificent before she
stepped one foot onto the set her
performance was inspiring and beautiful
even before she was born
this moment this movie was written in
the stars destined from the beginning of
time now I didn't read that other real
review before writing that I meant it as
a joke that brie Larson's sheer
existence in the film is enough reason
to love it but then some real film
reviewer actually make that same point
in all seriousness my god of course the
other the other meme that you get with
these movies is that angry what you
always hear is the same thing with
ghostbusters what you always hear is
that the media what the media says well
it's a bunch of angry white men a bunch
of angry white men are losing their
minds over this movie they they they
hate that this movie is out there in
fact writing right on cue The Daily
Beast has an article with that title
verbatim the title is how brie Larson's
Captain Marvel made angry white men lose
their damn minds
meanwhile no man is losing his mind over
this men are just going it's okay it's
not great you know I
mm-hmm that's what men are doing that's
being called losing their minds what men
are just saying yeah feminists are the
ones who are losing their minds so the
way that the conversation goes is men
say yeah you know didn't love it and
then feminists say why didn't you love
it you sexist you Pig you scum why don't
you die and then men say okay okay take
it easy and then feminists say why are
you so angry calm down that's the way
that the conversation always goes so
what is this all about
why why does it you know now every time
there's a one of these female action
movies which by the way is nothing new
you know there have been female led
action movies for decades a Kill Bill
came out and what like mm 2 or 3 and
that was a female ad led action movie
and there have been there have been
plenty before since and before then but
why has it now become this why is it now
this this whole thing where it comes out
it's this whole event and everyone has
to pretend to like it
well I think it just shows the
incredible insecurity of feminists yet
again insecurity is what drives most of
their positions most of what they do and
say really just comes down to insecurity
feminists are insecure about the fact
that they themselves are not men this
has always been the paradox of feminism
is that they hate men but they also want
to be men they hate men because they
themselves are not men and they wish
they were which is pretty typical I
guess maybe it's not even paradoxical
it's pretty typical that when you people
generally hate whoever they are envious
of and so they see what they see is that
is that men have a lot of action movies
there are a lot of action hero men and
so they want their own the only reason
they want it is because men have it
that's the only reason it's not because
they find anything objectively good
about it or it's just they want it
because men have it and then they want
theirs to be just as good and if you say
that there's isn't just as good or if
it's or whatever they have they have a
temper tantrum over it and that's the
way it goes it's the same thing with I
mentioned before feminists are very
insecure about the fact that about about
you know sense about about humor comedy
and they know that most of the greatest
comedians in in history have been men
most of the funniest movies that have
come out have been written by men
directed by men starring men and so they
have a they they get very insecure about
that and they insist no no we men are
funny men have funny things we need we
need to have funny things too because we
need to be just like men and so they
have their own comedians in their own
movies and some of their comedians are
legitimately funny and some of their
movies are legitimately funny but some
of them really aren't but you're not
allowed to say that you have to pretend
and right when it wina when someone like
Amy Schumer comes along and really she's
not funny at all and has no actual real
jokes but you have to pretend well she's
a woman though so we have to grade her
on a curve and pretend that she's that
she's funny so that's that's what it
comes down to it just kind of this
really silly insecurity on the part of
feminists alright switching gears here I
want to talk about something that has
been gaining a lot of steam recently and
that is the issue of paid family leave
okay paid family leave is an idea that
is gaining bipartisan support which is
which you should always be since what
the media tells us is that anytime
something is getting bipartisan support
that means it's probably a good idea and
we should pay attention to it but in
reality it goes the other way is that
when something is getting bipartisan
support that's when you should be really
suspicious of it because I mean it's bad
enough when one group of idiots likes a
certain proposal but when both groups of
idiots like it well then now you know it
must be really bad right but it's you
know it is getting a lot of some
Democrats love the idea Republicans are
getting behind it Trump is in favor of
it I was at CPAC last week and Rick
Santorum was there stumping for for paid
family leave he had this big sign that
was out near brought broad crack it's
called broadcast Row where all the you
know TV stations and radio stations and
stuff are set up at CPAC and he had this
big sign there that said something like
paid family leave is a conservative
position or conservative priority now
paid family leave of course is not a new
idea many employers offer paid leave to
their employees for maternity sickness
other medical or family issues and so on
but some employers don't offer it
especially small employer small
businesses often cannot afford it
because if you've got a small business
and you've only got five employees
you probably can't afford to pay one of
your employees to be gone for five weeks
you just can't afford it you don't have
the resources for that especially
because when you pay your employee to be
gone for five weeks you also have to pay
someone else to temporarily come in and
take that person's place and so now it's
double the cost and you just can't
afford it for it but Republicans and
Democrats now want to mandate it and
that's the way it always works with
government right they see how there's a
certain thing that isn't happening or at
least isn't happening enough according
to them and it's not happening enough
because it just people can't afford it
they can't do it and so the solution
from our from our illustrious
politicians is to just mandate it is to
say oh well you can't afford it well you
have to do it now though that's how
we'll solve that problem they want to
tell employers that they must offer paid
family leave and not just that they must
but these politicians are going to
mandate how much time will be offered
and for what reasons and they're gonna
set all the other parameters as well
right so they are sitting up on their
perch in DC they're surveying the whole
landscape and declaring what everyone
should do they're making their
declaration this is what everybody has
to do not taking into account individual
cases not taking into account exceptions
not taking into account the the
situation the actual real-world
situations that employers find
themselves and not taking anything into
account but the political spectacle of
it all that they care about is that the
voters will see them will see the
politicians trying to give them the
voters something that's all that's all
that they want to that they want now
there are different ideas for how to
structure this kind of entitlement plan
and it is certainly an entitlement plan
it's a literally an entitlement
politicians are saying everybody is
entitled to three or five or twelve
weeks of a paid family leave different
ideas I had a structure at different
ideas how to fund it but no matter what
it will be costly no matter what private
citizens and businesses will be footing
the bill for this thing whether they can
afford it or not and remember the the
whole reason why some employers don't
have paid family leave is because they
can't afford it I'm sure that if you if
you have a business with five employees
you would love it if you actually had a
business with five hundred employees and
you could afford to do something but you
but that's just not the situation that
you're in I it is my call me an optimist
but you'd be the first to ever call me
that but but call me an optimist I don't
think that there are very many employers
out there who declined to offer paid
leave just because they're like you know
grinches or Scrooge's or whatever and
then and and and they just they don't
offer it because they want to see their
employees suffering you know when I
think of private business owners
I don't unlike a lot of people I don't
imagine some evil old white guy you know
chomping on his cigar sitting behind a
big oak desk
you know petting his white cat and
laughing maniacally to himself when he
thinks about all the all the all of his
employees who's not giving paid leave to
that that's not what I imagined it when
I think of business owners I think most
of them are just you know they oh they
own small to medium-sized businesses and
they're trying to make it by and it's
you know they don't have a lot of room
to work with and if they if they're not
offering these kinds of programs it's
because they just can't they'd love to
but they can't so I think when we talk
about something like this we don't even
need to get
to the cost of it we don't even need to
get into the practical aspects which is
which is an important aspect of course
and I think it is the cost alone is
prohibitive but I think that's not
really the point there is rather I would
say a philosophical question here and
it's a philosophical question that at
some point we just sort of stopped
asking ourselves but I think we need to
ask ourselves this question and that is
what is the point of government you know
fundamentally what is government
supposed to do why do we have a
government what is its job and I really
think that a lot of people they go their
whole lives they never ask themselves
that question they never develop any
sense of any idea of what the government
even is or what it's supposed to do yet
they still have all these opinions about
different policies they support and
different laws and everything and it's
all kind of haphazard and in you know
they just all they they come up with
these with their with their positions
and their opinions it's all isolated
right there's nothing coherent about it
I think most people don't bother coming
up with a coherent kind of philosophy of
government well fortunately our founding
fathers did bother coming up with a
coherent philosophy of government and
their their philosophy was that
government exists to protect our Liberty
you know to protect our rights that's
that's why we have government that is
the fundamental philosophical reason why
government exists I think most people
today although again they don't really
stop to think about it they don't come
up with a coherent idea of it but when
it comes down to it what they really
think is that the government exists to
protect fund facilitate our lifestyles
and our comfort government exists to
provide for us government is
the the the ultimate daddy he it's it's
everyone's daddy that's just up there
and giving us what we need that that's
the idea of government that a lot of
people have and when you have that idea
of government then I guess it makes
sense
something like paid family leave in that
case just makes a whole lot of sense
because it would make our lives a lot
easier
if we had paid family leave it would
make us a lot more comfortable and so
the government should give us that
because that's really that's that's the
argument that most people have it's just
it would be nice to have that thing it
would make my life easier and so the
government should see that I have it
that's that's all why should I need any
more reason than that it's it's it's
something that I want it would be good
for me it would help me and so you know
the government should give it to me and
that's why when you have this discussion
and you you know you take the position
that no I don't think the government
should provide that a lot of people when
they hear you make that argument they're
going to respond by explaining why that
thing itself is good
so like you'll say no I don't think the
government should provide paid family
leave and so the response will be
yeah but paid family leave is good it
would really help me is it you know they
respond by explaining all the ways that
paid family leave is good well no but
you know you're not arguing that there's
anything wrong with paid family leave
itself paid family leave is great you're
just arguing that the government should
mandate it that's the point
just like I don't think that the
government should be involved in health
care I'm not against health care I think
health care is great I think it's great
to people who are the doctor I think
everyone it's a wonderful thing
modern medicine is a wonderful thing I
just don't think the government should
be involved in it but there
that look that that nuance that really
obvious an important nuance right that
obvious distinction that many people in
our country today don't understand they
don't understand the difference between
opposing something in and of itself and
opposing the government's involvement in
that thing they they don't they cannot
comprehend the difference and that's why
we just instead of we need to get
control the entitlement state we need to
get control of our debt problem that's
what we need to do but instead we keep
going in the opposite direction more
debt and more entitlement and a lot of
it is because of this fundamental
confusion that plagues many many voters
all right let's see we know it's
something else I wanted to to mention
maybe I'll save this for tomorrow but
Shawn Oakman is a former football player
at Baylor University and he was he was
supposed to be you know potentially a
first-round draft pick in the NFL but he
was accused of and charged with raping a
woman and this was like two or three
years ago and it completely derailed his
career he wasn't drafted by the NFL so
he's been out of football now for three
years and just a couple of days ago he
was found not guilty of of sexual
assault and whether or not he'll be able
to get his career back remains to be
seen but this is an interesting case and
it shows the the it shows the the
consequences of an accusation even if
even if it's even if it's a false
accusation but I think well because
there are a few interesting emails I
want to get to us I think we'll save
that discussion for tomorrow so I want
to get into that in
in more detail into the specifics of
this of this particular case let's go to
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com is the email
address this is from this is from Matt's
we had a Matt right in yesterday so the
Matt's are all uniting I think that's
great this is from a different Matt he
says you talked at length day about how
Alexander Kaiser Cortez does not appear
to take her own doomsday prophecies
seriously because she continues to
utilize supposedly world-ending
technologies if she really thought cars
and planes were destroying the planet
you say she'd be screaming at the top of
her lungs and fear and or anger or at
least taking the metro more often I
couldn't help but notice a correlation
between the way AOC chooses to live
despite her beliefs and the way
pro-lifers live despite theirs I for
instance impro life above all else which
means I truly do believe that 60 million
innocent human beings have been legally
killed over the last quarter century one
might suggest that given this horrifying
injustice I ought to be tirelessly
riding in the streets while I do
dedicate a good amount of time to
activism certainly I could be doing much
much more simply put practicality plays
a big role in the time I spend marching
or writing how much different difference
could I a single person truly make is it
worth sacrificing a family a job I think
that to some extent climate change
activists could use this same excuse the
problem according to them is so massive
that their individual contribution or
sacrifice is negligible is it worth the
massive inconvenience will they really
make that much of a difference let me
know what you think love the show keep
up the great work I think that is an
excellent point and I totally agree that
pro-lifers often don't live like they
believe what they're saying and that's a
problem they don't do enough we don't do
enough I don't do enough and you're
absolutely right about that but I think
there is a difference between the case
of the pro-lifers who are not involved
enough in activism and in fighting the
cause and this okay environmentalists at
least the ones like a like occasional
Cortese the extreme
once they believe that things like cars
and planes are directly causing directly
bringing about the end of the world okay
Cortez says that the world is going to
end in 12 years so there's a difference
between choosing not to actively take
steps to address the issue that you
claim to care about which many
pro-lifers are guilty of and on the
other hand continuing to do a thing that
you claim is going to destroy all human
life in a very short amount of time so I
think that there's a difference between
those two things in other words I'm not
blaming environmentalists for their lack
of activism that's not my point I'm not
saying that environmentalist should be
out there doing more activism marching
more and all that kind of stuff
[Music]
I'm not blaming them for what they're
not doing I'm blaming them for what they
continue to do which is to directly
contribute to the destruction of human
civilization in their minds anyway so I
just think you know as a pro-lifer you
might you might stop and say to yourself
I could be doing more I need to be out
there more and that's true we could all
be doing more but if you are an
environmental environmental extremist
and you really believe that because we
drive around in cars and use fossil
fuels the world is going to come to an
end it's one thing to not go out in the
streets screaming about it which I'm
kind of happy that they don't do they do
it sometimes but I'm if they want to cut
back on that I'm fine
there's demonstrating that in and then
on the other hand actually getting into
a car and driving around in it while
thinking that you are directly
contributing to the
if you maybe in a very small way but you
are directly contributing into the end
of human civilization I just I can't
imagine doing that I think another way
of looking at this is if you're an
environmental activist who believes this
then you must conclude that it is
objectively morally wrong to drive a car
how could it not be if the world is
ending in 12 years because of this kind
of thing I mean must be objectively
wrong to do it and yet you continue to
do it and so so yeah I I think that
there is a there hypocrisy
I think is quite a bit more extreme and
pervasive this is from fish he says hi
Matt huge fan of the show thank you for
your comments on Michael Jackson I agree
that his legacy should be ruined because
of his atrocities however when someone
on Twitter pointed out that one of your
favorite authors had a history of
stalking and harassment you said if you
only like
artists without demons you are really
limiting yourself how do you reconcile
those two views where do you draw the
line on what demons are acceptable and
what aren't thank you another great
point I think if I remember that
conversation on Twitter four months ago
I think that was in reference to I think
it was a reference to David Foster
Wallace I believe crack me if I'm wrong
which is one of my favorite writers and
he had a lot of demons I mean the guy
killed himself so he certainly had a lot
of demons there's no question about that
and he was accused of I believe
essentially stalking and harassing
another write another author who he had
he was infatuated with and I think he
had a relationship with her and you know
on and off again I'm pretty sure anyway
I guess the way that I reconcile this is
by taking into account two factors one
is the severity of the claim against the
person the seriousness of the demon that
we're talking about and to the valley
you of their art and then also three I
guess I'll take a third thing into
consideration and that would be time
like how long ago did this person live I
do think that matters now Wallace and
Michael Jackson they both lived and died
around the same time so that isn't a
factor in this discussion in this
comparison but I do think that the
historical proximity of the of the
person's life matters to some extent
because if they did a horrible thing and
their victims are still around and still
affected by it
then I do think you weigh that as
opposed to someone let's say some
Renaissance artists who lived and died
400 years ago and so anyway but let's
focus on points wanted to I guess as far
as one goes I just think that serial
child molestation is in a whole
different league than what from from
what some someone like Wallace was
accused of doing I mean there are demons
and then there's being a pedophile and I
and I just think that the two things
aren't even close if Wallace was guilty
of stalking and harassing a woman or
even being abusive at various points of
his life that matters I mean it's bad
but it just doesn't come anywhere close
to seeking grooming and then raping
seven year old boys it's just it's not
in the same league it's just not it's
that you you can't even compare them you
you you can't even put them on the same
Venn diagram there's there and if you
did there's not going to really be
hardly anything in that middle bubble
right so yes I think we have to allow
for the fact that artists have demons
everybody does everyone is flawed an
artist especially / the stereotype tend
to be kind of messed up we know that but
child rape again is something something
entirely different
that's worse than murder in my mind it
is literally the worst thing a person
can do the worst so where's the line I
don't know exactly but I think the
mine is somewhere before you get to the
worst possible thing so Michael Jackson
did the worst possible thing he was the
worst kind of person that can exist and
yeah there's a at some point you cross a
line and I wherever that line is I don't
know exactly but I am positive that
Michael Jackson is on the wrong side of
it and then factor to I guess we don't
even need to discuss but it does matter
I think Wallace was not just a genius
but someone who had a profound insight
of the human condition he wrote things
that were often hilarious startling
poignant sometimes beautiful and so you
do way that you have to think do we want
to throw this away can we afford to
throw this away or is it too valuable
so whatever Michelangelo is accused of
doing well we cannot afford to get rid
of the Sistine Chapel or the piano as a
species we just can't afford it it's too
beautiful too powerful too valuable that
art stands on its own has taken on a
life of its own and we can't be without
it it would be a tragedy for the human
race
if the Sistine Chapel were to crumble
and the fact that he lived 500 years ago
I think also makes a difference in my
opinion so we have to ask I guess is
thriller or Billie Jean or beat it are
these things so incredible so beautiful
so powerful so absolutely staggering in
their genius that even serial child rape
even serial child rape which occurred as
recently as this past decade couldn't
cause us to stop enjoying it
I would say no that's my opinion
finally from Travis who says hi Matt I
always enjoy hearing your perspective on
all things related to the Bible and
especially enjoyed your commentary on
the young earth theory well that makes
one of you Travis in searching for
related topics I stumbled upon dr. Frank
Turek of cross-examined he seems to have
a good approach for defending the
Christian faith just curious if you have
read his book I don't have enough faith
to be an atheist and hope to get your
thoughts on his arguments I am familiar
with Frank Turek I haven't read his book
but I've seen some of his lectures and
some of his debates I think is a
brilliant guy great debater very
impressive in that format now I will say
though that I have grown to really
dislike that particular argument which
is in the title of his book I don't have
enough faith to be an atheist right and
I know that this is a theme that tarik
hammers on all the time a lot of
Christian apologists especially these
days it's kind of a common thing
especially in modern times among
Christian apologists where they they say
this thing about a know no atheists are
the ones who have faith they have too
much faith it takes more faith to be an
atheist than it does to be a Christian I
guess in Christian apologetics this has
been determined to be some kind of very
powerful argument and I disagree now
there are some arguments that Christians
and atheists make which the other side
finds formidable and serious so as a
Christian I think that the Atheist
arguments arguments like the argument
from suffering the argument from divine
hiddenness these are formidable and
serious arguments from atheists that
Christians have to grapple with and on
the other side I know that even guys
like Richard Dawkins have admitted that
the fine-tuning argument the arguments
about these universal constants which
make life possible and which seem it
seems so highly improbable that they
could have happened on their own now
even something like Richard Dawkins has
said that that is a serious argument but
then there are arguments that both sides
make which the other side's just roll
their eyes at and treat with total
disregard and contempt because they find
it to be lazy and ridiculous
so as a Christian that's how I treat the
whole
the whole bit about God as a magical sky
fairy right quick Christians the as an
atheist the moment you say that the
moment you make that argument every
Christian Tunes you out because it's so
ridiculous it's so silly it's it's a
childish off-base characterization that
we cannot possibly take seriously but on
the other side I know that atheists feel
that way about the it takes more faith
to be an atheist argument that's just
not an argument that any atheist
anywhere takes seriously I would
challenge you to find one single atheist
who will say that he is that he stopped
in his tracks by that argument there's
not gonna be an atheist who says whoa
wait a minute it does take more faith
for me to be an atheist no what they do
when they hear that argument is they
just roll their eyes and they say okay
all right Ya Ya Ya Ya Ya
that's because the whole point of
atheism is that they're saying to us
okay you've made a claim about the
Christian God about Jesus about
Scripture and so on and we've listened
to you and we don't believe your claim
we don't accept it we just don't believe
it we don't think you've met the burden
of proof we are declining to believe
what you are saying much in the same way
that that we as Christians will listen
to a Muslim and say okay I hear what
you're saying about Muhammad in the
Quran but I don't believe III do not
believe what you're saying that is not
what I believe I am declining to believe
in Muhammad the Prophet and in a lie I'm
declining to believe that now obviously
I think that atheists should believe
what we're saying I think that there are
good reasons to believe what we believe
obviously but declining to believe a
claim does not require faith it requires
the lack of it's the opposite of faith
it declining to believe what someone is
saying is that means that you don't have
faith in what they're saying may
you should have faith in it but you
don't that's the point
and if we have any chance of
communicating with atheists and maybe
even convincing them we need to show
that we understand their basic position
we you can't engage with someone if you
don't if you're refusing to understand
what they're saying to you and it's the
same for them so that that's why it's
it's it totally shuts down the
conversation the moment that an atheist
goes oh you just believe in a magical
sky fairy because then as Christians we
say you're not listening to us you're
just not listening that's not what we're
saying we don't believe that and if you
if you insist on painting our views that
way we can't have a conversation not
gonna work and it's the same thing on
the other side where atheists are
segments that's not what we're saying
we're not saying that we have faith in
some other proposition we're just
declining to believe your proposition
and so when a Christian says yeah but
you must have a lot of faith to do that
they they all they say is okay you're
not listening to me and so that's why a
theist and Christians they end up
walking away from each other because the
one side is saying sky fairy the other
side is saying you have more faith than
us and then both just walk away and say
alright you I you know it's I just
believe strongly we need to listen to
what the other side you just listen to
they listen to the argument they're
making at least and and then you can
engage with it so no atheists don't have
faith atheists have a lack of faith by
definition right and here's my other
problem not only is the atheist have
more faith than us thing kind of a
mischaracterization and a straw man but
here's the biggest problem it also turns
faith into a dirty word it seems almost
that were ashamed to have faith and so
we're saying we don't have faith you do
we're not the ones with faith you're the
ones with faith why even get into that
competition I why are we ashamed of it
we should be saying yes we do it you
don't have faith we do we're proud of it
we're proud to have faith we should be
trying to prove to them that they have
more faith than us that that is a
faith is a virtue right why would we
even be doing that and faith faith must
be more than an assumption you know a
best guess based based on the evidence
you know it's more than that we believe
that faith is basically the testimony of
the Holy Spirit within us right is the
internal testimony of the Holy Spirit
that's that's what that's what faith is
so when we believe in God it's not just
about having weighed the evidence it is
also about the internal testimony and
that's and that's and that's what faith
is so when we say that atheists have
faith what are we saying that their own
internal testimony from the Holy Spirit
is that God doesn't exist it doesn't
make any sense
so yeah III appreciate him I appreciate
a lot of Christian apologists I just
think that I read a lot of this stuff
and I watch a lot of you know lectures
and things from from Christian
apologists i watch a lot of debates
you know I basically obsessed with all
this stuff and there are certain
arguments that I've just come to maybe
loathe that's too strong a term but I've
come to really dislike because I find
them to be so incredibly ineffective and
and that so that's one of them but
thanks for the email thanks everybody
for watching we'll leave it there
Godspeed